c'est la grande semaine de présentation
des modèles haute couture printemps-été
88 certains couturiers sont plus
attendues que d'autres c'est le cas
cette année de christian lacroix qui
avait triomphé avec sa dernière
collection d'hiver alors plutôt que de
vous présenter un défilé traditionnel
nous nous sommes attachés à découvrir
bien comment un couturier avait d'abord
l'idée est ensuite concevez un modèle
jusqu'à sa réalisation
nicole cornu langlois triomphe cet après
midi au final de la collection de
christian lacroix
parmi les 80 modèles présentés voici le
tailleur vincent inspiré du zouave de
van gogh
c'est dans le désordre sympathique et de
ce bureau rempli des souvenirs de sa
provence natale que christian lacroix a
inventé les trois cents dessins à la
base de sa collection sélection
rigoureuse ensuite pour conserver ce qui
mérite d'être créée le drame qu'il faut
faire de nouveau tout en restant fidèle
à soi-même sans se répéter on prête
c'est ça il faut créer une image sans en
être prisonniers je voulais pas non plus
j'aime pas vraiment faire de la couture
tableau jeu quand même que ça c'est un
vêtement un vrai vêtements et je vais
pas prendre le tableau de van gogh et
puis regarde exactement combien de
centimètres
il a sous tâches pour la faire
exactement 1 c'est simplement une
aspiration
on pense en destinant au poids du tissu
on sait que ça va être un tissu fluide
souple ou rigide et le dessin est
ensuite découpé sur une toile a
transcrit les volutes rouge sur la poêle
pour obtenir à l'essayage une
transposition précise une chose qui est
plate en volume à c'est à dire que par
exemple là on avait pensé la sphère plus
autres pas ce cap là ça nous semblait
plus est en fait à l'essayage on s'est
rendu compte qu'il valait beaucoup mieux
la faire plus basse que c'était beaucoup
plus joli sur le corps voilà tout ça
c'est les va être des incrustations de
robes et les applications picot une
centaine d'heures de main d'oeuvre sans
compter les broderies avant d'arriver à
l'essayage suivi de rectification j'aime
bien quand mon dessin devient réalité
sur le champ les femmes qui portent sur
le bal petits pas une fausse plaque et
mais plus qu'une recherche technique au
niveau de la toile etc
c'est une ambiance et des couleurs c'est
une longueur c'est un accessoire c'est
d'équilibrer justement entre la jupe les
épaules le chapon la mode alors rejoint
le spectacle angoissé jubilation de la
présentation ce tailleur est proposé à
60 mille francs sur mesure bien sûr